die modewelt tummelfeld verquere ideen
leider schaffen als hoch kreativer akt
mittels im ausdruck statement einer der
vielen disziplinen in denen sich die
data ist innen vor 100 jahren ausgetobt
haben mit großem selbstinszenierung
sveland hoben sie modische manifeste auf
schiene und straße als weibliche antwort
auf bürgerlichen normen und
rollenmodelle befreiend und provokant
und heute wo findet sich dass da eben
noch die mode chefin der
frauenzeitschrift annabelle hat
geforscht
die idee vom neuen ausdruck
die haut ist glaubt größte vermächtnis
wo dabei ist ja irgendwoher weitergabe
an team oder subversiv gegen vernunft
und ästhetische normen verstoßen da der
prinzipien finden sich auf
unkonventionelle modeshows irritierende
inszenierungen und performance is mit
form sprenger kraft ganz nach da da man
hier ist natürlich ein asketisches ist
irgendwie sich anders und ich sag jetzt
mal hier siegte dort auch im grundgesetz
trainings aber für eine modestrecke im
jubiläumsheft hat gartner zusammen mit
fotograf lucas was man kreationen
schweizer designer in szene gesetzt
gesucht und gefunden hatte die stücke
über den jungen kreativen designer im
alter der dadaisten zu ihrer wilden zeit
nur hier sagt sie finde sich die
unbändig kite die überbordende
kreativität
die helme absolut kein kommerzieller
aspekt im hinterkopf und ich glaube das
ist ein wichtiger moment zu erwischen
neues findet danke ich wahnsinnig
wichtig dass im haus wieder über ist
also im extreme landet in den werken von
designerin flacher jahr hat göthner dass
der moment in der verspieltheit den
fittichen zugang entdeckt jahre sagt sie
entwerfe grenzen verwischen der anti
fashion das extreme liege weil ihr im
alles oder nichts ist ganz wichtig dass
das kleidungsstück meter solches
definiert sondern offen bliebt und die
freiheit das thema stelle möchte ich
kann alles sie es kann es ein polizist
könnte es kann das band objekte
dekomaterial
mit radikaler konzept mode handgemachtem
strickt und häkelt design sich auf
linien das geht sagt ja vielleicht
andere themen als ihm dabei es muss dazu
mal wo sie ist bedürfnis km bis zu
revolutionieren wie sich der
massenkonsum und verdächtigen wir dir
schnell laufen die falschen moniz gefühl
hatte sie dem entgegentreten und das
langsame und gegensätze die datei ist
innen haben pionierarbeit geleistet
auch modisch einen urknall gezündet bei
so manch mutiger jungdesignerin halt
dieser noch nach